so a new king has chosen to
send you to the Nights Watch
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
safer to travel more Lord smart more than I can
say for this lot get these prisoners to work bring
the girl need a new cupbearer you're my queen I
told you I don't want it you are my queen I don't
want it you are my queen this is not life when
will he be as he was when Sun rises in the West
sets in the east when the Seas go dry when the
mountains blow in the wind like leaves I never
wanted a crown you will always be my Queen
Daenerys how quick don't want it your back
[Music]
thank you tell me what are you doing
cooped up in here when the weather
outside is so normal my ones brought a
jackass and a honeycomb into a brothel
[Laughter] you serious you should
consider yourself lucky lease your
balls won't freeze off you take great
defensive dwarf jokes but love telling
you new jerks why is that because I have
balls and you Denver if you'll have me
[Music] dracarys
I just want you to know
I wish do you ever look at someone and wonder
what is going on inside their head let me smash
please hey girl you want some tail I'm ready
I won't let you down you're not going but
I'm better than every other than no one you
come with me you die here yeah Negro that's
all you had to say and who has a better story
than brand the Broken Bow that's not so much
[Music]
if the city surrenders they will
ring the bells and raise the gates
please if you hear them ringing
the bells call off the attack
[Music]
ZDNet I've got this you know
I keep telling everybody they
should move on and grow some do they let us there
[Music]
[Applause]